so I decided to come here to the
Barcelona supercomputer which is the
third fastest supercomputer in Europe it
cost 34 million euros to build check it
out but joining me here is Guillen Russo
physics computer science extraordinaire
Guillaume what's your role here I'm team
leader in mechanical engineering and I
lead a team of let's say 30 people
uh-huh and just how fast is this
computer
it's 11 para flops so it corresponds to
10 to the 16th more less operations per
second per second 10 to the 16 yeah
which is equivalent to let's say 80
thousand computers normal computers so
80,000 powerful computers running in
conjunction is what's behind us okay
insane so what kind of projects are you
guys working on who who uses this
computer well we seem like very tiny
things like atoms molecules through
medium things like it's a cardiovascular
system respiratory system airplanes and
huge scale systems like Astro physics
cosmology Wow you're dealing with all
rounds of science you know biology
chemistry physics yeah another challenge
is to couple all these scales and to
make to simulate the whole world so you
know cuz I guess I mean I guess you
could argue that the universe in some
ways is coupled it's a couple system
yeah right so ideally you're just trying
to you're taking this off of see much
smaller scales and trying to simulate
them and calculate what is going on
through this machine so I heard that
apparently you guys were very
instrumental in the discovery of
gravitational waves now that's really
exciting to me because that's what I
wrote my dissertation on back in 2003
before we had discovered these things
these ripples in space-time and
how was how was there enough time
involved in that well it was a project
called LIGO and was awarded a 60 million
our simulation which means that well to
simulate what you've just said and it
would correspond to it's a 1,000 years
of simulation on one CPU weight so this
if they had run the simulations to try
and discover these gravitational waves
it would have taken a thousand years if
they've done it on a normal laptop also
this is a very very issue in few years
in a few days you have have your
simulation done so this gonna be cheap
to hire out for these teams of
researchers where does the funding come
from it's public funding excuse me yeah
so yeah that's it you're relying on the
governments to help with this
fundamental science research yeah you're
right actually we are a stage where we
have to promote supercomputing to
industry so that they can see they can
solve their problem
[Music]